why don't we take a few phone calls the
number is 6 1 7 8 30 for 750 we are
accepting all questions comments
subjects trolling whatever we don't know
what's going to happen let's take our
first call name in town were you calling
from hello then mom you're on right now
uh name is Michael I'm from Atlanta
Georgia all right what's on your mind I
was just wondering since I know you're
not too big of a Hillary supporter right
but you just really don't want Donald
Trump is there any Republican candidate
that you would have supported uh I mean
if the question is are there Republicans
that exists that I'd consider voting for
for president the answer is yes if the
question is were there any of the 17
that ran this year that I would vote for
over Hillary Clinton I think the answer
is no I mean is there anyone is there
anyone you would support uh well I mean
I probably have more of a hatred for
Hillary than you I was done with like
Ted Cruz you would have supported ted
cruz over her I mean are you like are
you an evangelical Christian out of
curiosity no but I kind of align more
conservative values which is not too
much of a fan of throat is there a
particular issue on which you really
like Ted Cruz's position but not Hillary
Clinton's um I'm not too sure on click
restore this new on immigration right
now but that's the really great ride
with Hillary so what don't you like
about babies in a drug dealer um I think
it's like the massive increase in a
refugee immigration and just like the
recent leaks that came out on the open
border stuff ok but so I think we've got
to break it down piece by piece is there
something in so you don't want Syrian
refugees coming into the u.s. at all um
well I mean currently since we have such
a huge problem already with illegal
Mexican immigrants and I would just have
an overall reduction in immigration
yeah it might look good unit did you
know Mike that more more immigrants are
going to Mexico from the US then coming
in did you know there's a net outflow of
Mexican immigrants currently actually
wasn't aware you were aware but I would
research that Mike it sounds like
there's a lot there I think you're doing
a good job trying to keep up with a lot
of these issues but I would check into
some of the facts here and see if that
changes your views at all I do really
appreciate the call check that net
Mexican outflow of number and maybe
we'll get a chance to talk again in the
future I do have to move on